hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter labelled
cold war 2.0 targeting China is off the
ground in gaining momentum some say
China must pay for the pandemic while
others claim Beijing is an existential
security threat to the Washington
centric world still others say
Washington can't concede we live in a
multipolar world now cross knocking
china and joined by my guest Tom Watkins
and Norville he is president and CEO of
TWD & Associates a global business and
educational consulting firm based in
Michigan as well as a regular
contributor to China us focus comm with
an emphasis on building ties between the
east and west and in Singapore we cross
to Jim Rogers he's an international
investor and director of a group all
right gentleman crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want I was appreciate
alright let me go to Singapore Jim let
me go to you first here we hear a lot of
bluster coming out of Western capitals
particularly the United States and the
media depending on what side of the
aisle you're on but it's all China's
fault China must pay something must be
done it's always the manageress
something must be done Madison that's
the age we live in something must be
done but you know I look at all of it
and then a lot of it's just tough you
know and it's just a knee-jerk reaction
and of course falling back upon old
paradigms like the Cold War that was
that ended in 1991 so I mean as you all
as you all absorb it here and you're a
financial guy so I trust you more is
there a strategy out there oh I don't
trust politicians that's for sure and
you know Asia very well is is this this
this you know to a Cold War 2.0 against
China is there a strategy that you see
then you can delineate it all go ahead
Peter throughout history all over the
world when things go bad politicians
blame the foreigners they always blame
the forest they have different skin
different languages different religion
different food they smell bad there
food smells bad everybody loves to blame
the forest and that's what's happening
now China is the most prominent of the
farms and the most successful so we're
blaming the forest I mean it's a total
absurdity if you ask me we should be
working together to bring prosperity to
everybody but that's why I'm not a
politician I guess there's so many
responses for me but I can't do it on
this program let me go to you you know
Jim really puts it really very squarely
I think here I mean first of all the the
US and many of its allies are not coming
through this pandemic very well they
would show that they were unprepared and
particularly in the United States and
and this is not to attack any particular
politician that's not my point here my
point is is that the when globalization
it reveals what globalization has done
the Chinese took globalisation and built
an economy in the United States and the
in the Western world created financial
Asian of the financialization of the
economy very different approaches to
globalization but overall one player
makes stuff and exports it that people
want and the other one will displace
with funny money all the time and this
is something that no one really wants to
talk about in the West because it is not
to their advantage actually it's very
much to their serious disadvantage go
ahead well thank you at first Jim thanks
for not wearing a bow tie I thought I
was going to be on with two bow tie
affection audits and be the odd guy out
clearly what we've seen as a massive
change over the last 40 years I grew up
right outside of Washington DC as a boy
and remember when China was not much
different than North Korea was for us
today it was a forbidden place and my
mom telling me you know eat your peas
the Chinese children are starving well I
wanted to mail them to him because I
didn't want to eat them but you
fast-forward over the 40 years and China
has risen up as Mao said in 1949 at the
standard of the gate of Tiananmen Square
the Chinese citizens have stood up and
clearly they have stood up
people have risen up out of poverty over
the last 40 years in the United States
has those people so when Jim talks about
it is non-politician I've kind of
evidence low in government and private
and nonprofit world blame has always
been a part of Americans playbook and
certainly blaming people as he pointed
out they're different that us but what
we need to do in my estimation is change
that paradigm around and when people
start pointing the finger at other
people the American people have to ask
how does Blaine help them how does it
restore their 401 how does it help get
them back to work and if you think
you've just got a D couple from China
and that's the end of the game I think
you got another thing coming
well Jim would stay with the decoupling
issues because I think it's very
important I can understand the knee-jerk
response I mean we saw the supply chains
particularly in the medical sector in
the United States left wanting grossly
left wanting in many ways but decoupling
well there is it be coupling going on
but it's not being reported or in all in
Western media is that Asian countries
are beginning to decouple from the
United States not from China okay and
that is something that is a trend that
is growing before this pandemic that was
going on that we will see look at the
data as it comes out but you know the
this mantra you know we have to cut
ourselves off from him well it from from
China but you know that again is
politicians talking out of their sleeve
and that's what I can say television
police but you know I don't see a lot of
maybe the Titans of business are gonna
be leaving China anytime soon because
well that's where they make money okay
so I mean this will end up being an
issue an internal issue in the United
States because after 40 years of
investing in the Chinese market
I don't think seeing a profit I don't
see them coming back any time soon
unless you want to start nationalizing
industries go ahead Jim well Peter trade
wars have never worked for anybody
nobody has ever won a trade war
whether it's decoupling or tariffs so
anyway you want to put him mr. Trump
either doesn't know history or well he
actually thinks he's smarter than
history he doesn't care about history he
has it in his brain and his friends
around him all think the trade wars are
good and at bashing the Chinese
I mean various people in the Republican
Party have made it very clear this
election is going to be run on bashing
China and that's what they're doing they
look around they say we how are we gonna
win this election the easy way is to
they think is to bash ina is it good for
America no of course not
we should all be trading together you
know America buys a lot from China China
buys a lot from America
the Chinese are ahead of us in some
technology but we're ahead and others we
should be working together the idea that
we're going to decouple and say to the
Chinese we won't trade with you how does
that help America how does that help
anybody how does that help China maybe a
few more Americans will get a job for a
while but there are 325 million
Americans we're all going to have to pay
much higher prices for everything do we
want to start buying our shirts from
Illinois I don't think so they'll be
more expensive than they probably won't
be as good I think that these jobs
aren't coming back to the United States
I mean that'll be the political rhetoric
but what you will see is automation and
and robots back in the American factory
clearly you're gonna see some swabs and
surgical gallons and other medical
equipment kind of be an important sure
but to think the Rouge plant the Ford
Motor Company plant that I worked my way
through collagen here in Detroit is
going to come back and there's going to
be a hundred thousand people with strong
backs and not much to think because your
job is just to tighten that nut isn't
going to happen if those jobs do come
back to the United States they're coming
back to automation to robots and not
there's thirty five forty dollar an hour
high
those killed with jobs here in the
United States you're exactly right
but even if well maybe if they come back
with robots yes fine but normally
America is not a cheap place a fishing
place to do business to manufacture the
products will be much higher price than
they would be if they're made somewhere
I mean this is economics which has been
around for a thousand years we all know
that Sun there's comparative advantage
and that's the way the world works sure
we can all buy expensive Fords again
that break down I would prefer not to do
that I would prefer Americans to do the
things that they're good at and let the
Chinese and other people do the things
they're good at you know the timing of
this is bizarre because here you have we
don't know all the details because we
don't have all the economic data yet but
I mean I think it's very fair to say
that the US economy is in deep recession
right now it's not depression depending
on a depression I think it's Carly I
always been careful because we don't
have those numbers yet but I mean it
looks like it's moving in that direction
and so the powers that be at least a
good part of them want to go on this you
know new cold war with China when the US
economy is flat on its back I mean these
people have any common sense I guess
that's a rhetorical answer go ahead I
think it's really a six-month strategy I
mean this is until November third I
think is election day strategy this is
and I've watched it here in Michigan is
very people point out this China's
always made at the boogieman certainly
when election time comes up and
certainly in the industrial Midwest here
in the state of Michigan which is seen a
lot of its manufacturing base and keep
in mind that in this election it's
really going to be a few states that are
competitive it's going to be Wisconsin
and in Michigan and Pennsylvania which
are they are going to be there and so
let me assure you the bumper stickers
ship child to China is going to resonate
a whole lot more than anybody giving
economic theory or geopolitical theories
about ways and that we should engage
with China
my hope is that it's only a six-month
strategy and either because the American
people make a different choice and hence
we have some different policies going
forward but sure clearly after the
election there's gonna have to be some
sort of pivot because the path were on
right now seems mutually destructive in
my estimation Peter be sure to
understand that what what Tom said there
is an election in America in November
and everything is consumed by that
election they don't care about you or me
or my kids or Tom's kids they care about
winning that election no matter what it
takes
they're ruining the country for my kids
they're ruining it for me because it's a
political issue Tom they're willing to
go down this path of ruin ization to
make some kind of hollow point it is and
it's frightening to me I mean what I
would have loved to have seen is this
pandemic struck up and right after we
signed the quote phase 1 trade deal with
China which to me was more transactional
than transformative but what I would
have loved to a scene with real
leadership was rather than playing
seesaw game where one country has to be
down for the other one to be up imagine
if rather than where the path were wrong
that if Xi Jinping and Donald Trump
would let's pull the world together
let's find a way to address this
pandemic this health care crisis in the
economic tsunami that it's unleashed
imagine if we were sitting down not
trying to find a zero-sum game of
politics but as I think it was to pony
who said all politics are local and
you're seeing this nationalism politics
play out not only in the United States
but also was she in China today okay
it's all very counterproductive
gentlemen or I'm gonna we're gonna jump
in here we're gonna go to a short break
and after that short break we'll
continue our discussion on the new cold
war against China staying with our key
[Music]
welcome back to cross that where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
to remind you we're discussing China
[Music]
okay let me go back to a gym in
Singapore
listen it's kind of broaden out the
discussion here let's ask let me have
some very simple questions number one is
China a military threat to the United
States not at the moment I don't think
America has enough nuclear bombs they
could blow up every city in China if
they had to so I doubt seriously if in
2020 China is a military threat to the
US they might be someday but not today
that's one of the things that's being
you know that's one of the solutions to
the problem which is like is you're
somewhat counter productive to in
comparison they disgust me on the first
half of the program I mean we have you
know we have the leading arms control
official of the United States saying
that if necessary we can we can spend
them into oblivion I mean it seems to me
that this is just mind boggling here I
mean I agree the United States and China
are competitors they may even be
adversaries okay but that is certainly
not a of a recent contemplating military
action because it seems to me that
military action is at the very end of
the spectrum if you feel definitely
threatened but we're nowhere close to
that right now but it seems that's one
of the first positions they jump to is
how can we carry a view with the Chinese
oh yeah there's only been economic humps
that have been dropped and as Jim is
pointed out this is all about a
six-month strategy for the next for the
next six months law everything about
election you know remember after a 911
Toby Keith the country music singer you
know courtesy of the red white and blue
will put a boot in your ass it's the
American Way we tend to kind of default
to that and that blame strategy again
going to war with the second-largest
world economy going to war with 1/6 one
fifth of the world's humanity seems
absolutely ludicrous to me but it may be
just enough to get enough votes to keep
a particular person in power
for four more years but one of the
things that Xi Jinping doesn't have to
worry about is a leader for life what is
the threat I mean I know you and I have
the same answer I don't see a threat
well my time is surrounded by military
bases China is surrounded by a myriad of
alliances that the United States is
involved in that is gets very
complicated to get out of control one
mistake and we can help August 1914 all
over again that's why I think that you
know these alliances create more
security threats than they alleviate
okay but that may be a topic for another
another program here but you know one of
the things I find very fascinating being
a trained historian and I'm going to
address this to both of you is that
where is this impetus come from and it
seems to me is it you know for the
Western domination even hegemony of the
world it is about a 500 year time scale
okay 500 years and and a lot of people
fail to remember they they didn't these
colonizers they didn't go out looking
for free gold or silver they went out to
proselytize they wanted to bring
Christianity to the world it's a basis
it's a it's a missionary messianic
impetus here well today the the West is
largely the Christian us okay like that
impetus is still there that we must we
must bring our values to others because
we know better they don't and it's it's
it's it's such a mind it's almost
impossible to confront because it is a
it has a messianic religious ten-inch to
it and then look out lately the
treatment of China is in the presence of
China must be brought to heel to heel
okay
deconstruct that kind of language
okay I mean it's very or to Orientalist
view of the rest of the world go ahead
the Middle East has experienced up for
the last half century from the West
let's point down
well one of those I think I could look
at is a chocolate and we're quick is
that you know I remember my first trip
to China in 89 walking down a building
on the Bund and in Shanghai and seeing a
map of the world from a Chinese
perspective because up until that point
every map of the globe
I saw the United States was dead center
I had to rub my eyes I bought one of
those maps to remind me they're not
everybody sees the world from our
perspective this is a tremendous honor
for me as a young guy in his 30s my
first trip to China that happened to
coincide with Tiananmen Square so I
think that we need to take a broader
view of the world and understand some of
that history that that you were talking
about Peter every country does this the
French did it's a Spanish city you said
before we were gonna save the world for
Christianity the Russians did it the
Russians were gonna save the world from
mr. Marx I mean nobody wants nobody is a
Marxist anymore they all want to be rich
but you know this is the way human
beings have worked for thousands of
years we're better than they are
and they should do what we say well I
mean do you know what I'm saying this is
a Maui my viewers will understand this
I'm still with Jim on this one here I
mean bring it closer to home is
Americans this is this American
exceptionalism that I'm talking about
and even questioning that you know
you're you're thrown out of the church
as it were okay you can't you can't say
that well you actually should say it
because American exceptionalism as is
practice now and has been practiced for
decades is against the national
interests of the country and for its
people okay for its people all right and
and again you know where do you both
gentlemen are focusing on the election
fair game here but when that election is
over and the this pandemic has been
stamped out look at the wreck
it's left behind and you want to start a
trade war with China I mean wow
what that's a harebrained ideas is
crucial is accused of doing go ahead
Peter America is exceptional with the
largest debtor nation in the history of
the world and the debts of skyrocketing
every day I mean we were two months ago
six months ago our deaths from onion
comprehensible and in the last month or
two they've added another few trillion
trillion with a T to the American debt
yeah that's exceptionalism no gotten
into this situation has gotten out
without a problem crisis what you want
to if you want to add to it you want to
add you want the adversary the new enemy
to buy your tea bills so you want you to
buy the debt but you're the enemy okay
that's an exceptional interesting
situation go ahead tom you want to jump
absolutely that's the point that I was
gonna make is that who's gonna buy our
debt the stuff that we continue to rack
up but a lot of this issue to me is and
president Trump has been a master at
this is getting the American people too
cheap chase the next overawed what we
should be really doing in America is
looking more at addition and
multiplication as opposed to division
and subtraction and what I mean by that
is we need to begin to invest in the
American people when I go to China and
use WeChat I don't have to touch
currency I can we chat anything and
everything when I can get on a bullet
train and go from Beijing to Shanghai
which used to be at a 10 or 12 14 hour
train trip and now I can do in a few
hours
China has begun to surpass us and what
we need to be doing is investing in
education and infrastructure in
workforce training and retraining so
that as as the kids that are now thirty
years old work in a factory those jobs
are not gonna be there in the future and
they're not going to pay a livable wage
give them what's going on and until
America begins to quit pointing to the
other guy and begins to invest in the
American people
in the American economy we're going to
continue to have
this is false choice in front of us and
it's very sad in troubling they think
the thing didn't Jim you know again
we're reading that the mainstream press
where they're not a lot very many
intelligent people you know the Pentagon
needs so more money or it's you know to
finish the pivot to Asia you know it's
always welfare for the
military-industrial complex but not as
Tom was pointing out here you know in
this conflict in this sphere right now
it's who's going to be best at R&D and
and and that's that that is this this is
what they will define this adversarial
conflict and and almost nobody in
Washington seems to get it okay go ahead
well unfortunately the next war is going
to be you know on the internet or with
with electronics yes somebody's some
troops are gonna have to go in and clean
up whoever wins but know that the
generals fight the last war that's been
happening throughout history the next
war is going to be electronic and
unfortunately for us as Americans the
China turns out something like 10 or 20
times as many engineers every year as we
do in America a lot of them are bad
engineers I'm sure but some of them are
very good you've heard of Alibaba you've
heard of I do you've heard of you know
$0.10 I mean some of those engineers are
good and some of them are sitting in
garages figuring out how to Roy in
America ok if we can add to that Tom a
lot of the engineers and generally
produced in the United States are
foreign-born I just would like to
there's a good cartoon that goes out
it's this Americans always wanted to see
more of its children in math and science
and then they showed a picture and the
picture shows American children of
Indian and Chinese descent they're
performing very well in those areas but
that is exactly the point is that China
doesn't have to get it right for all of
its people with 1.5 1.6 billion trained
billion people they don't have to get it
right for all they do think it right for
a song in education is really going to
be the future sitting in a mirror
University likely today as a future
president a leader of China one of the
message that those individuals are
hearing and seeing what kind of
relationships are they building between
the most important bilateral
relationship in the world today when you
think about it every major world issue
he's going to intersect at the corner of
Beijing and Washington DC so how our
respective leaders whether it's our
current leaders our future deal with
these issues are going to impact the
people of China the people of the United
States and for that matter all of
humanity that's why the stakes are so
bloody high in the last 20 seconds here
because unfortunately you know the way
whether the US has constructed is every
four years but Thomas absolutely right
it's the horizon as much only 20 seconds
go ahead Jim my daughter just came back
from China every fifth grader in China
spends one hour per day on coding I live
in Singapore we don't even do coding in
Singapore much less in Iowa one hour per
day for 10 year-olds well I think that
is the best way to end this program
because it shows the difference here and
who's creating a viable future and who
is not okay I want to thank my guests in
Norvell and in Singapore and I want to
thank our viewers for watching us here
at RT see you next time remember across
Hopkins
[Music]